188th Congress and House Republicans now
are on the verge of becoming a total
clown show if they're not careful but
despite the cheering and Elation from
Democrats and the mob and the media it's
not a dire situation yet now here's
where we are at this hour a contentious
battle for speaker is underway after
falling short of the 218 votes needed
leader Kevin McCarthy is now in the
political fight of his career as a small
but seemingly determined group of
lawmakers now stand in the way many of
them are pushing for Congressman Jim
Jordan to be the next speaker of the
house but Jim Jordan is already
supporting Kevin McCarthy take a look
for what purpose does the gentleman from
Ohio seek recognition I Rise to nominate
Kevin McCarthy for Speaker of the House
to my friends here on this side of the
aisle I would just say this
the differences we may have the
differences between Joyce and Jordan or
Biggs and bacon they pale a comparison
to the differences between us and the
left which now unfortunately controls
the other party and I think Kevin
McCarthy is the right guy to lead us I
really do or I wouldn't be standing up
here giving this speech
now Jim Jordan he told me personally he
doesn't want to be the speaker of the
house and wouldn't accept it even if
drafted the congressman is one of more
than 200 plus people that voted for
McCarthy to make him speaker today along
with Steve scalise and Jim Comer a
Marjorie Taylor Greene and many others
now tonight I'm putting aside my
frustration but for those of you still
worried about supporting McCarthy I want
you to consider this tonight sometimes
you have to think through politics now
McCarthy has already publicly laid out
his commitment to America plan that is
exactly the America First Maga agenda
that so many of you I know like secondly
McCarthy vowed to investigate the Biden
family's Financial dealings and that
means an investigation into President
Joe Biden not just Hunter he also will
investigate the origins of covid-19 the
disaster of the Afghan withdrawal the
politicized FBI and the weaponization at
the Department of Justice and of course
they will deal with why wide open
borders to our South he has also
publicly committed to blocking Biden's
radical socialist agenda using every
means at his disposal and to reassure
those lawmakers still worried about his
commitment now this is something worth
paying attention to the very few people
are talking about McCarthy is conceded
to a very low threshold what is called a
motion to vacate in other words only
five Republican lawmakers can force a
vote at any time to remove McCarthy from
the speakership many of the people that
oppose him today ask for that very thing
and then the bar got raised again and
again and again and again and the bar
keeps shifting this is a very powerful
insurance policy if Kevin doesn't keep
his promises a level of accountability
that Nancy Pelosi did not agree to in
her latest stint as speaker and yet
after all the concessions all the
assurances I continue to ask the
holdouts over and over again okay what
is it you're looking for for what what
would help you better serve your
constituents at home I've asked many of
these members for weeks about this and I
rarely got an answer I mostly got radio
silence a lot of crickets now it is time
to get serious with a small majority in
the house it's critically important for
Republicans to come together as an
important check and balance to the Biden
Administration and the Democratic
Socialist Party and tonight we ask the
question oh how about this question what
would Ronald Reagan say what would
Ronald Reagan do now as President Reagan
famously told the staff quote the person
that agrees with you 80 percent of the
time is a friend and an ally not a 20
percent Trader Republicans they would be
wise to heed that advice as of right now
19 Republicans they are determined to
block McCarthy and that means lawmakers
cannot be sworn in committee assignments
are delayed the Republican
investigations are stalled and now this
is not a big deal as of today but if we
lose a day or two but if this fight goes
on and on for day after day week after
week and the Republican agenda totally
stalls out you can forget about holding
Biden accountable pretty much for
anything and the country will be angry
and frustrated and they will feel
betrayed and you can forget about
securing the Border you can forget about
exposing the bias the corruption is the
FBI or have they been politicized is the
doj being weaponized and by the way you
can forget about you know holding Dr
fauci's feet to the fire I think the
time has come for that even worse some
of the McCarthy holdouts they are now
even reportedly threatening according to
reports to vote for Democrat Hakeem
Jeffries if they don't get their way
needless to say that would be a massive
betrayal to every single person in the
country that voted for a republican as
one party Democratic rule will then
continue at the end of the day the
America people they voted for governance
they voted for oversight they voted for
checks they voted for balances they
didn't vote for Republicans to go to D.C
and waste time and bicker among
themselves and grandstand and with the
right to vacate and the motion to vacate
available to them there is a way to hold
Kevin McCarthy accountable if he doesn't
keep his promises but again despite
fantasies from the media mob I do
believe this fight for speaker will be
resolved Republicans ultimately will
come together work will continue
hopefully in the near future hopefully
sooner than later hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else